TWENTY TWENTY- BOUNCE ACTUALLY
RECALL ROLE PLEASE. KALRA HERE
FLORA HERE CARILLO. YEP THERE
GONZALEZ JONES SAWYER HERE
THREE OF US. THANK YOU ARE AND
THEN ITEM OF AB TEN FORTY SEVEN
FONG HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR AND SO THE ONLY ITEM ON
THE AGENDA IS AB EIGHT EIGHT
TWO SAHRA CARTY WHO IS ON HIS
WAY APPARENTLY RIGHT NOW. OR.
FILLED WITH. A TEXTURE TO IS ON
HIS WAY CAN. WE'LL SEE WHAT
THAT MEANS. RIGHT. THIS IS. AND.
FOR THE. WE GOT A LOT OF. YEAH.
OKAY THE. FOR THE PARTY. HAPPY
BIRTHDAY ONLY. SO. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO WE HAVE AB EIGHT EIGHT
TWO FROM THE CENTER MCCARTY
MISTER MCCARTY WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY YES THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR FIRST OF ALL WORKING WITH
THIS OVER THE BREAK THIS BILL
IT TALKS ABOUT THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACTED
DISCRIMINATION THAT REALLY IT'S
ABOUT ADDICTION AND WE KNOW WE
HAVE THIS CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA
WITH AS GOOD A DICTION AND MANY
OF YOU HAVE SEEN THESE TV
COMMERCIAL THAT SAYING ONE OF
THE PROMISING WAYS TO GET OUT
OF THIS ADDICTION MISTER WITH A
CALL AND EIGHTY- MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT- BE BUT NOT
FRIENDS A BOX ON OUR THE
COMMENT- PRESCRIPTIONS THAT
INDIVIDUALS CAN. GET OFF THEIR
HOPE YOU A DICTION- GET
STABILITY BACK IN THEIR LIVES
AND GO BACK TO WORK BUT THERE'S
A BIT OF A DISCONNECT BETWEEN-
WHAT EMPLOYERS THINK IS BEING-
ON DRUGS IN BEING INTERACTING
WITH THAT THE WORKPLACE IN
BEING- AT- ON MEDICATION TO
DEAL WITH IS ACTUALLY A
DISABILITY THAT YOU HAVE TO GET
BACK INTO- MAINSTREAM OF
SOCIETY AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WORK WHERE
CLARIFYING- CODIFYING
PROTECTIONS FROM THE AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITIES ACT IN THE
STATE LAW. THAT MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT SOMEBODY WHO HAS AN
ADDICTION AN OPIOID ADDICTION
CAN GET ON THIS TREATMENT- WITH
THE SUPERVISION OF THEIR OF
THEIR DOCTOR AND GET BACK TO
WORKING BE GAINFULLY EMPLOYED
RATHER HAVE THAT THAN THEM-
BEING ON THE PUBLIC DOLE- SO
WITH THAT I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY WE ARE WORKING WITH ALL
PARTIES TO CLARIFY SOME OF THE
ISSUES AND HOW WE IF THIS
PASSES TODAY WILL WILL WORK
WITH THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IN THE CHAIR AFTER
FURTHER I WORK ON ISSUES BEST
RELATE TO LABOR THANK YOU. BYE
THANK YOU AND AS ALWAYS EACH
SIDE HAS. UP TO SIX MINUTES AND
YOU CAN DIVVY IT UP ANYWAY
YOU'D LIKE. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS RACHEL L<c.cyan>G</c>
SENTIMENT SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY
WITH LEGAL AID AT WORK THE LATE
WORK IS A PUBLIC INTEREST LEGAL
SERVICES OR XIN THAT FOCUSES ON
ADVOCATING FOR WORKING AND LOW
INCOME WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES- I'M HONORED TO BE
HERE TO DISCUSS THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF AB EIGHT EIGHTY
TWO LEGISLATION WHICH WILL
BENEFIT MANY OF THE CLIENTS WE
REPRESENT. I'D FIRST LIKE TO
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP SURROUNDING
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE WITH THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC AFFECTING THE
LIVES OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
PROTECTING THE EMPLOYMENT
RIGHTS OF INDIVIDUALS AND
RECOVERY PROGRAMS IS ESSENTIAL
DISABILITY RIGHTS HELPLINE AND
CLINIC WE HAVE HEARD FROM
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE FOUGHT SO
HARD TO OVERCOME THEIR
ADDICTION ONLY TO BE TERMINATED
FROM OR DENIED EMPLOYMENT
PRECISELY BECAUSE THEY'RE IN A
RECOVERY PROGRAM THROUGH WHICH
THEY RECEIVE MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT OR IN
EIGHTY. AND EIGHTY IS AN
ADDICTION TREATMENT PROGRAM
THAT COMBINES THE USE OF
CERTAIN PRESCRIBED MEDICATIONS
INCLUDING BIãU PRINT A FRIEND
NOW TRACKS OWN IN METHADONE
WITH COUNSELING AND BEHAVIORAL
THERAPY IN EIGHTY IS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED TO RESULT IN
SUSTAINED ADDICTION RECOVERY
AND AS EFFECTIVELY IMPROVE THE
SURVIVAL RATES OF PEOPLE
STRUGGLING WITH OPIOID
ADDICTION UNFORTUNATELY MANY
EMPLOYERS MISTAKENLY BELIEVE
THAT THE MEDICATIONS USED IN
ANY T. WILL PREVENT AN EMPLOYEE
OR APPLICANT FROM BEING ABLE TO
SAFELY PERFORM HIS OR HER JOB.
HOWEVER THAT CONCERN IS
UNJUSTIFIED RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT WHEN TAKEN AS PRESCRIBED
MEDICATIONS USED IN IN EIGHTY
DO NOT ADVERSELY AFFECT A
PERSON'S INTELLIGENCE MENTAL
CAPABILITY PHYSICAL FUNCTIONING
OR EMPLOYABILITY NEVER THE LESS
DISCRIMINATION PERSISTS AND
ACCORDING TO THE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ADMINISTRATION
EMPLOYER DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
ME T. PARTICIPATION IT'S EXCUSE
ME AND EIGHTY PARTICIPANTS HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO REDUCE THE RATE
OF PARTICIPATION IN THIS
LIFESAVING TREATMENT PROGRAM.
TO BE CLEAR SUCH.
DISCRIMINATION IS ALREADY
UNLAWFUL UNDER STATE AND
FEDERAL. DISABILITY LAWS. ARE
THESE PROTECTIONS ARE SET FORTH
IN THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT AND
INCORPORATED BY REFERENCE INTO
THE- EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT AND
CORRESPONDING REGULATIONS.
HOWEVER BECAUSE WE ARE SEEN
EMPLOYERS CONTINUING TO
UNLAWFULLY DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
CALIFORNIA WORKERS TAKING
LEGALLY PRESCRIBE MEDITATE
MEDICATIONS AS PART OF ANY T.
THESE PROTECTIONS MUST BE
CLARIFIED THROUGH EXPLICIT
INCORPORATION INTO THE
STATUTORY LANGUAGE OF THE FIFA.
AB EIGHT EIGHT TWO WOULD
ACCOMPLISH THIS IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATION WHICH IS SO VITAL
TO MANY OF THE INDIVIDUALS WE
SERVE AT LEAST LATE AT WORK.
ONE OF OUR CLIENTS WAS RECENTLY
THRILLED WHEN HE WAS
CONDITIONALLY OFFERED A JOB
THAT WOULD PROVIDE ECONOMIC
SECURITY FOR HIM AND HIS YOUNG
FAMILY HE HAD PERSEVERED
THROUGH MANY OBSTACLES IN HIS
LIFE. INCLUDING OVERCOMING AN
OPIOID ADDICTION AND COMPLETING
AN INTENSE VOCATIONAL TRAINING
PROGRAM ONLY ONE MORE HURDLE
STOOD BETWEEN HIM AND THE JOB
HE DESIRED A DRUG SCREEN
MANDATED BY THE EMPLOYER. A
DRUG SCREEN THAT TESTED
POSITIVE FOR METHADONE WHICH HE
HAD BEEN LEGALLY PRESCRIBED
THROUGH HIS IN EIGHTY PROGRAM.
THE EMPLOYER WITH DO HIS JOB
OFFER BASED ON THE SCREENING
DESPITE ITS AWARENESS THAT MY
CLIENT WAS NOT USING IT
ILLICITLY BUT AS PART OF HIS
EFFORT TO OVERCOME PAST
ADDICTION. THIS CLAIM IS NOT
ALONE HIS STORY IS THE STORY OF
SO MANY OTHERS AND RECOVERY-
FACE SIMILAR DISCRIMINATION. IN
THIS TIME OF CRISIS WE SHOULD
BE ENCOURAGING PEOPLE WHO ARE
SEEKING HELP FOR THEIR
ADDICTION NOT FORCING THEM INTO
UNEMPLOYMENT. AND THEREFORE
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB EIGHT EIGHT
TWO WHICH WILL CLARIFY THAT
WORKERS WHO STRUGGLED WITH PAST
ADDICTION INCLUDING THOSE
PARTICIPATE IN IN IN IN EIGHTY
PROGRAM ARE PROTECTED AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS MARICA
YOSHIHARU WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PLACEMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
AGO EVERYTHING THAT MY
COLLEAGUE RACHEL HAS JUST SAID-
WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD IN
CONTINUING TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT SUCH AN
IMPORTANT AND TIMELY ISSUE. AND
AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT AS
WELL AS THE PROPONENTS AND
OPPONENTS ON THESE PROTECTIONS
ALREADY EXIST UNDER OUR
DISABILITY DISCRIMINATION
ACCOMMODATION LAWS. BUT WE HAVE
IS A PATCHWORK OF FEDERAL AND
STATE LAW IN VARIOUS
REGULATIONS SO I THINK IT WOULD
BE EXTREMELY HELPFUL TO MAKE
THESE PROTECTIONS REALLY CLEAR
AND EXPLICIT. ON AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED TO REALLY ENSURE THAT
WORKERS WHO ARE OVERCOMING
ADDICTION WHO ARE NO LONGER
USING WHO ARE IN TREATMENT ARE
ABLE TO. HAVE THEIR JOBS
PROTECTED AND LIVE PRODUCTIVE
LIVES SO FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE SUPPORT. RAINY X.
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA BLISSFULLY RIGHTS
BELIEVES THAT IF YOU'RE GOING
TO GET YOUR LIFE TOGETHER YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO LOSE YOUR JOB.
THANK YOU. A LOS IS SUPPORT
ANYONE OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS IT'S SO NICE TO SEE ALL
OF YOU TODAY THANKS SO MUCH- MY
NAME FOR CRITICS AND I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY WE ARE HERE CURRENTLY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT EIGHT
TWO WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS HOWEVER WE
DO HAVE SOME SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE AMENDED
LANGUAGE- WITH IN THAT IT SOME
OF IT WAS NOTED BY THE
COMMITTEE STAFF DAY DEFINITION
OF A LEGAL DRUG IS NOT DEFINED
AND DEFINITION OF ILLEGAL DRUG
IN CALIFORNIA IS DIFFERENT THAN
THAT AND FEDERAL LAW. SO THAT'S
A LARGE CONCERN FOR US
ADDITIONALLY SOME OF THE
DEALING WHICH WAS ADOPTED BUT
LANGUAGE IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
WERE CONCERNED THAT IT COULD BE
INTERPRETED TO MEAN THAT AN
EMPLOYER IS ONLY ALLOWED TO
DRUG TEST IF WITH REGARD TO AN
INDIVIDUAL IN THE
REHABILITATION PROGRAM NOW WITH
REGARD TO OF THE UP ALL THE
OTHER ISSUES LAID OUT IN THE
EIGHTY A SUCH AS THE DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION AND ALL OF THOSE
ISSUES SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
ALL OF THE LANGUAGE FROM THE
EIGHTY A WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
ACTED OR WE COULD LOOK AT.
SOMEHOW I'M JUST REFERENCE TO
THAT EIGHTY LANGUAGE
ADDITIONALLY WITH THAT- AT THIS
POINT WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT ALL
OF THESE PROTECTIONS ARE
ALREADY IN THE LAW WE FEEL THAT
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT TO LOOK AT
IT BUT IF IT'S GOING TO- IT
TAKE ON THE FEDERAL PROVISIONS
IT SHOULD REFLECT THAT EXACTLY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY WE LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH AUTHORS
OFFICE AND HIS STAFF ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. A WELLS
OPPOSITION. OR IT. HI KATIE
HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION REPOSE
FOR THE REASONS STATED THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS WALKER
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA SHEET
METAL AIR CONDITIONING
CONTRACTORS- OUR NUMBER ONE
GOAL IS TO MAINTAIN
UNAMBIGUOUSLY A SAFE WORK
ENVIRONMENT IN CONSTRUCTION
THAT'S OUR BIGGEST DEAL. AND WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT INCREASING LIABILITY FOR
EMPLOYERS TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE MEMBER I'M NOT SURE WHAT'S
IN THE LANGUAGE- THIS IS. YEAH
I'M LOOKING FOR TO SEE WHAT THE
FINAL LANGUAGE IS- OPIOID
CRISIS HAS STRUCK THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
PARTICULARLY HARD. ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL ARE WE IN OUR
LABOR PARTNERS HAVE MADE THIS A
TOP PRIORITY. ON BUT NOTHING
TRUMPS A SAKE SAFE WORK
ENVIRONMENT AND SO ON WE'RE
LOOKING TO FIND THAT SWEET
SPOT- WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT
TO INCREASING AMBIGUITY WHEN IT
COMES TO WORKER AND PUBLIC
SAFETY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
YOU'RE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. I'D LIKE TO
ECHO ON THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER- WE CERTAINLY
HAVE CONCERNS ON. OF THE HEALTH
AND HEALTHY AND SAFE WORKPLACE
MAINTAINING HEALTHY AND SAFE%
WORKPLACE FOR WORKERS- WE HAVE
BEEN ENCOURAGED BY WORKING WITH
A SIMILAR MCCARTY AND HIS
STAFF. OF BOUT THE DIRECTION
THE BILL'S GOING TO GO ON BUT I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT
ACCORDING TO THE FDA- SIDE
EFFECTS OF METHADONE INCLUDE
LIGHT HEADEDNESS DIZZINESS AND
SEDATION. SO HAVING ANYBODY ON
A JOB SITE THAT IS EXPERIENCING
EITHER SYMPTOMS- CAN BE FATAL
NOT ONLY TO THAT WORKER. AND
SPECIFICALLY- BUT TO WORKERS-
AROUND HIM OR HER IT'S A VERY
DYNAMIC VERY ACTIVE PLACE. SO
WITH THOSE CONCERNS IN MIND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND STAFF TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY FORWARD BECAUSE WE
AGREE THE OPIOID CRISIS IS-
INSIDIOUS. AN ALL CONSUMING SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION. RIGHT
WILL BRING ABOUT MISS MCCARTY.
AND YEAH AND QUESTIONS. YEAH
COMMENTS HIM OKAY I'M AND
PROBABLY BOB WANTED A FEW
MEMBERS- IN THE ASSEMBLY- AS
DIRECTOR OF ASSET MANAGEMENT
FOR THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
THERE'S ACTUALLY WORK WITH
PEOPLE IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY. AND. BUILDING TRADES
CARTER LE CHRISTIANS PLUMBERS
DRY WALLER'S- A WHOLE SLEW OF
THEM THAT WERE PROCEED LA. AND
I KNOW UNFORTUNATELY FIRST HAND
WHAT CAN HAPPEN. WHEN SOMEONE'S
IMPAIR AND I'VE SEEN THE
DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS OF THAT OF
IN SOME WAYS I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS. WHAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT IT FROM THE
WORKER STANDPOINT MAKING SURE
THAT THEY'RE IN NOW IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT BUT THEY'RE SAFE.
AND SO I WOULD HOPE. THAT AS WE
AND- I'M GONNA VOTE TO GET THIS
OUT I AM A RESERVE MY BOAT
LATER- AS IT MOVES FORWARD-
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE MISTER
MCCARTY YOU. GENERALLY ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUALS- THAT GET THAT
RETURN TO THE WORKPLACE I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THIS DRUG AND WHAT
IT DOES BUT I DO KNOW WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO BE PAIRED- OR TO HAVE
EMPLOYEES IMPAIRED. AND THEN TO
SEE REALLY TRAGIC ACCIDENT
HAPPEN AND SO- THAT IS MY MAIN
CONCERN. ABOUT. EVEN JUST DRUG
TESTING IF YOU STILL NEED. A
YOU KNOW WHEN WE HAD
CONSTRUCTION SITES WE STILL
NEED TO DO IT EVEN IF SOMEONE
WAS OFF. OF A CERTAIN DRUG AND
HAD REHABILITATED CONCEIVE LA
WE PROBABLY GAVE MORE CHANCES
FOR YOU TO REHABILITATE- DILLON
PROBABLY THE LAW ALLOWS BUT WE
GAVE THOSE CHANCES TO
REHABILITATE. BUT ONCE YOU GOT
BACK AND YOU START WORKING FOR
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
A PUBLIC WORKS OR IN
TRANSPORTATION AND YOU WENT OUT
IN THE FIELD YOU START WORKING
WITH HEAVY. DUTY MACHINERY IT
WAS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT-
THAT YOU WERE CLEAR HEADED AND
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
SO- IS MAYBE ONE OF. THE FEW
TIMES RIDE COULD KIND OF
ECHOING WHAT THE CONCERNS OF
THE CHAMBER- AND WHAT BUT THE
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO
THIS WORK. THAT YOU WORK
TOGETHER HOPEFULLY WITH THEM TO
PROVIDE- A WAY THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT WHO EVER COMES BACK
FROM THIS PROGRAM OR TREATMENT.
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THEIR
WORK WITH NO HARM TO THEMSELVES
AND THEN SOMETIMES TO THEIR CO
WORKERS. WHICH IT COULD HAPPEN
AND SO- I AND I BELIEVE MISTER
MCCARTY YOU YOU TRULY BELIEVE
THAT THAT WE NEED TO PROTECT
THE WORKER AND SO AT. WE HAVE
MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT WE
CAN RESOLVE THAT A WITH ALL
ENTITIES RIPPER. INVOLVE
BECAUSE THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO WORKERS.
THANK YOU SENATORS ALSO- FIRST
I'M OF THE BILL I AM GOING TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY I AM WORRIED
ABOUT THE TIME MEAN I'M BECAUSE
I DO FEEL LIKE THERE'S
DISCUSSIONS I'M NINE ASK I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO HOUSE WITH- IN
PARTICULAR IT. THE BUILDING
TRADES AND CONTRACTORS ABOUT.
THIS LANGUAGE- TO ENSURE AS AS
MISTER JONES SAWYER SAID THAT
THERE'S- WE WERE. HAVING SAY
PARK SITES WERE HAVING SAY
PARKER'S- BUT I JUST WANT TO
REMIND YOU BECAUSE THIS IS GOES
I BELIEVE TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WHERE ANTI CRUNCH SO LIKE AFTER
THIS HEARING I HOPE YOU GO- I
KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING TO
TALK TO THEM BUT LIKE LET'S.
GET SOME LANGUAGE ASAP. THANKS.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE THAN A
COMMON QUESTION SERRA CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I TO
OCCUR THE CONCERNSOF MY
COLLEAGUES ON ON THE DíAS
RIGHT NOW ESPECIALLY THE
LANGUAGE REGARDING- AN
INDIVIDUAL OR THE PHYSICAL OR
MENTAL DISABILITY COVERED BY
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
ACT IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT
ACTUALLY MEANS THERE ARE WE'RE
ALSO FACING A REAL CRISIS WITH
MENTAL CHALLNGES ACROSS THE
STATE. AND ADDING ADDING TO
THAT- I HAVE CONCERNS IN
GENERAL HOW WE WOULD ADDRESS
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES- AND I HOPE THAT
IN THE DAYS IN THE NEXT DAYS TO
COME. YOU'LL FIND SOME
SOLUTIONS AND ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS OF THE CHAMBER HAS
AS WELL AS THE TRAY. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ANY OTHER COMMENT
OR QUESTION. HAS IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE BILL. SHE SO THE
RENT I MADE WAS THAT A MOTION
THAT WE USE AS OUR SECOND. OKAY
THANK YOU SUMMER JONES SAWYER
SIMILAR GONZALEZ REMOVING IT-
AND- ALWAYS BRING ABOUT YOUR
FINAL COMMENTS ONE MAKE ONE A
COUPLE COMMENTS ONE- HAVING
WORKED AS YOU KNOW IS PUBLIC
DEFENDER OF OVER FIVE AND A
HALF YEARS MY TIME WAS A DRUG
TREATMENT COURT. TRYING TO. THE
ABILITY- MY CLIENTS AND GETTING
A JOB WAS ONE OF THE TOP. WAYS
IN ADDITION OBVIOUSLY DOING
THEIR ADDICTION TREATMENT WHEN
HAVE YOU TO GET SOMEONE BACK.
ON THEIR FEET BACK AS PART OF
SOCIETY AGAIN SO I TRULY- THINK
YOU'RE GOAL IS VERY LAUDABLE
AND I ALSO BELIEVE THAT NOW
MORE THAN EVER IN REGARDS TO
OPIATES CRISIS WITH. SPECIALLY
IF WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN MECHANISM MEDICATIONS
WHAT HAVE YOU THAT APPROVING
AFFECTED THAT WE- IF WE REALLY
WANT PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
REHABILITATE THEM WE SHOULD
GIVE THEM. ALL THE TOOLS
AVAILABLE INCLUDING THE TOOL OF
BEING ABLE TO BE EMPLOYED. AND
THAT BEING SAID I DO THINK THE
OPPOSITION ALSO HAS A LOT OF A
GOAL OF KEEPING A SAFE WORK
SITES I THINK THAT. THAT I
APPRECIATE- THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF DIALOGUE I KNOW EVEN AS
RECENT AS YESTERDAY. IN TERMS
OF THE. AGREEMENT FROM YOUR
SIDE TO. FROM YOU TO. A MAN
ALTERS THE LANGUAGE I KNOW
THAT- THE I. RECOMMENDATION
COMES WITH THAT COMMITMENT FROM
YOU AS WELL AS THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THAT. THAT SPOKE
WITH CONCERN TO ENSURE THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS AS SUMMER
GONZALEZ MOVE THE BILL-
INDICATED THAT- ASSURANCES
THAT. THOSE CONVERSATIONS ARE
GOING TO BE- COULD NOT JUST
CONTINUE BUT BE MEANINGFUL-
AND- THAT'S MY EXPECTATION AND
I THINK THAT'S EXPECTATION OF.
THOSE ON THE COMMITTEE AS WELL-
IN CONSIDERING THE AND I BOAT
ON THIS. SUMMER MCCARTY. YET
THANK YOU. BUT THE I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE BUT OF COURSE AND LET
ME JUST TRY TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES TO REASSURE. GOING
FOR TODAY. AND THERE IS A QUITE
A FEW THINGS BROUGHT UP BY-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND IT
INDIVIDUALS ME JUST. TRY TO
TACKLE A FEW THOSE ONE THERE IS
SOME QUESTION IT WAS A REAL SAD
ABOUT MARIJUANA. AND HOW THIS
MAY LEAVE IT AT THAT I DON'T
FULLER BONTA A COUPLE YEARS AGO
ABOUT A PROPOSAL FOR THAT.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO SET UP ALL
WE ARE- WE ARE FINE CLARIFYING
THAT TO TAKE IT OUT TO JUST.
BUT INSTEAD OF PRECAUTION TO
MAKE SURE THAT'S CRYSTAL CLEAR.
THERE WAS A CONCERT THIS IS
ALREADY. AT THIS IS ALREADY
REGULATION AND IT'S DUPLICATIVE
THAN MIKE. RESPONSES WHAT THE
PROBLEM CODIFYING UNDER STATE
LAW AND THAT WOULD BE MORE
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS. AND
THEN LASTLY I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT. YOU KNOW THE IRONY IS
THAT INDIVIDUALS COULD HAVE
CHRONIC PAIN. TAKING AN OPEN
EVERY DAY AND GO TO WORK. AND
THEN THEY CAN GO DOWN THE
SLIPPERY SPIRAL AND GET. DON
HEROIN AND START RIPPING OFF
THEIR NEIGHBORS NOR COLOR
GROUND THOSE PILLS IN THEIR
COUNTER AND SO FORTH AND THEN.
THEY GET A PROBLEM. TWO YEARS
AGO I SAT HERE IN A SEPARATE
PANEL AND HOPE WOULD BUILD MY
WITNESS. COMMERCIAL PAINTER HIS
NAME WAS STEVE. AND HE SAID
THAT HE BECAME ADDICTED. TO
PAIN. KILLERS AND HE WAS CASE
IN IT HI UP TIME THE GUY. LIKE
IT'S KIND OF A C<c.cyan> AS I HIGH.</c>
THE LAST FEW YEARS WE'VE SEEN
THIS NEW DRUG THIS AND MAKE
TEA. BEEPING AFFERENTS A BOX ON
WHAT THE OTHER ONE THAT. NO
TRACKS IN. A SHOW THAT HAS
LOWER LEVELS AND THE
INDIVIDUALS. DON'T GET HOT IT'S
THE THING THAT THAT THE GUY
WANTED TO DO EVERYDAY AS WAKE
UP AND BE FUNCTIONING. GO TO
WORK AND THE INDIVIDUAL. WORK
FOR A COMMERCIAL PAINTER IT WAS
A CONSTRUCTION WORKER HE'S HE
HE HE A SHELL LIKE MANY PEOPLE
MINISTRY OF THIS. NOT IS IN THE
SAY IT'S A WONDER DRUG BUT IT'S
ONE OF THE- GREAT TREAT
PROMISING TREATMENTS WE HAVE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY A LOT OF
PEOPLE TO GET BACK. INTO
SOCIETY GET BACK TO WORK AND
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE ALL ABOUT SO
I THINK THAT THERE. IS A SWEET
SPOT THAT WE CAN WORK OUT WITH
WITH THE- THE KID THE
OPPOSITION AND THAT CONCERN
OURS. NOT REALLY WORK CONCERNS
BUT I'M- AND THEN THAT'S OF
COURSE WITH THE- THE COMMITTEE
AS WELL. AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I THINK- THIS IS NOW I
THINK THAT THE DEGREE NOT ONLY
OF THE OPIOID CRISIS WHICH IS
BEEN- TAKEN MANY YEARS TO GET
US WHERE WE ARE BUT- THESE NEW
TREATMENTS AND I THINK THAT-
EMPLOYERS- THAT IS A SUMMARY
JONES SAWYER SAID HAVING.
WORKED IN THAT ARENA- THEIR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS SAFETY
AND SOMETHING IF YOU'RE
INTRODUCING SOMETHING NEW- TO A
WORK SITE WHETHER TO MEDICATION
OR TREATMENT WHAT HAVE YOU-
IT'S A COMMON UPON THEM. DID TO
DO THEIR DUE DILIGENCE TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
A SAFER EXCITE. AND THAT'S WHY
I THINK THE DIALOGUE AS TO WHAT
THESE TREATMENTS ARE WHAT THEY
DO WHAT THEY'RE PURPOSES. AND
FINDING WAYS TO NARROW. THE
FOCUS OF THE BILL AS MUCH AND
IT ALREADY HAS AS YOU
INDICATED- YOUR YOUR INTEREST
IN CLARIFYING IT BROTHER DOES
THAT. BUT I THINK THAT THE AYE
AYES WHENEVER YOU'RE DOING
SOMETHING NEW ESPECIALLY IN
WHEN THEY CUT DEALS WITH.
SOMETHING SO SIGNIFICANT AS.
OPIATE ADDICTION. AND WORK. IF
THE. TWO ISSUES THAT. DON'T
WANT TO. RISE UP THAT DOESN'T
REQUIRE. EDUCATION DIALOGUE.
AND I DO THINK THAT THERE IS. A
IN THE MIND TO BE HAD I THINK
IT'S A PRETTY NARROW. NEEDLE TO
THREATEN BUT I THINK CAN BE
DONE AND I HOPE YOU CAN GET
THERE AND THAT'S WHY. I SUPPORT
THAT MOVED TO STOP FOR A GIVEN
THAT OPPORTUNITY. I AM A NDA
THE ALSO. OKAY ABOUT THAT
AMOUNT OF SECTOR IF WE CAN.
CALL THE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
BOAT. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA FLORA NO CREO